We can welcome to another Zoom call.
We have a lot of questions that came in.
Are you're welcome to chat in questions as we go
and you're welcome to unmute yourself
and ask questions, but please just wait till we get
to the end of all these ones.
We can start taking for another questions.
Reminder to look at the announcements on the member site.
You all know that, but let's just jump right in.
Okay, first question.
We have put a reverse osmosis system in the house.
Please recommend what minerals you would replace.
So, I wouldn't replace any minerals.
You're not eating your minerals through your water.
So, there's a lot of misconceptions here.
So, I understand that if you look online,
people will say people that are selling a different system
other than reverse osmosis.
We'll say you shouldn't use reverse osmosis
because it's dead water.
It doesn't have any minerals in it.
You took all the minerals out.
And even companies that sell reverse osmosis units
will sell you this other little filter thing
that replaces minerals.
So, it's like a mineral tube or something like that.
I don't recommend you doing that.
Those are just earth-bound minerals.
So, remember this.
You can just remember this
that will help you understand.
There's minerals in the soil.
We don't, we're not created to eat dirt.
Plants eat dirt and they convert those minerals
into a form that we eat or cows eat
or animals eat and then we eat the animal.
So, we don't eat dirt.
Plants eat dirt, we eat plants
or we eat animals that eat plants.
So, we don't eat soil-bound minerals.
Can you get minerals through your well water?
Because it's got a lot of fire in it.
It's got other minerals in it.
Yeah, you can.
It's just not a good form of minerals.
Not well absorbed.
It could cause gut issues.
That's not how we get minerals.
Is there something wrong with heavy minerals in water?
No, necessarily.
We will get minerals through our water,
but that's not how we get our minerals.
Our usable minerals that go into cells and function
in all the metabolic processes that take place,
we get through eating meat that animals
are consuming plants or consuming plants.
It's a special double bonded to an amino acid
that plants convert from a soil-bound mineral
into the minerals that we can eat.
So, that's a misconception.
So, you see that out there?
If you're going to use a reverse osmosis water,
you have to add minerals.
No, you don't.
No, that's not right.
That's not true.
Reverse osmosis water is dead water
because it doesn't add minerals.
No, no, it's not.
So, a heavy minerals doesn't make it live water.
So, I mean, there's a lot of misuse of terminology,
misunderstandings, misinformation.
That's why I highly recommend you be very, very careful
what information you're leading off the internet.
You know, my life was a lot easier
when there was no internet in a lot of ways.
You're not competing with so much blasted information.
That's a just call me right before this meeting
because we're updating our stop fighting cancer book
to a new edition.
It's going to be out in, let's say a couple of months,
but probably a number of weeks,
we'll have it ready to go out.
And back in 2018, when I last updated it,
the pharmaceutical industry alone spent,
I think $72 million, just solely,
that's not an advertising,
that's solely in the what they did
to try to influence our senators and congressmen.
So, that was, that's what they spent.
The last data on that was on last year,
this by the second quarter of 2025,
so only two quarters, only half of 2025,
they spent 227 million just in lobbying congress alone.
227 million, so they spent almost $500 million
just in lobbying congress for pharmaceutical industries.
Well, I'm not getting my information
from television commercials and pharmaceutical drugs,
but if we could calculate how much people
are influenced by Instagram and Facebook
and TikTok and other social media
that is wrong information, it would just be so scary.
This is just one example of that.
So, we just have to be careful.
I would rather have you guys not be on social media.
I think it's healthier for us in multiple different ways,
not to mention having to fight the propaganda
of wrong information.
So, not to say that there's not good stuff on it too,
but there's so much bad stuff on it.
I just wish our cell phones would disappear sometimes.
Okay, next question.
Just finished 15 rounds of radiation to the chest.
Is it normal to have elevated CEA numbers?
Two weeks after treatment due to inflammation or something.
Is this a false read?
Because I feel great.
So, this person had metastasis to the lung.
It was blocking an air pathway,
causing deflation of the lung,
different fluid buildup, et cetera.
I highly recommended they do radiation
on their, there was a centimeter spot
or something, I can't remember the size of it.
They went through with the radiation
and it really helps kill the cancer.
Now, when you kill cancer quickly,
either through chemotherapy or radiation,
you are going to liberate the different enzymes.
So, remember, tumor markers, CEA, CA153, CA2729, CA199,
et cetera, et cetera, et cetera.
The tumor markers are different protein enzymes
that are normal at a certain level in the body,
but tumor markers are elevated if cancer is growing
because that cancer may be making more
than spilling more.
And you see an elevation of tumor marker value.
CEA is a tumor marker value.
But also, if cancer is killed quickly,
it's going to liberate that protein.
So, it's like the cells are going through what's called lysis.
So, when you use radiation or chemotherapy on cancer cells,
they don't die through normal acoptosis, some do,
but majority of them, especially with radiation,
that are going to all die through process called lysis.
That means the cell just literally blows up.
That means it spills all its contents.
And we end up getting a lot of what are called endotoxins.
Toxins from the explosion of that cell
that our body has to, ever, toxins don't just disappear.
Your body has to get rid of them
through the liver, through the kidneys.
And that's what, one of the things I can cause,
sickness, doing chemotherapy and radiation,
not feeling well in a lot of malaise of the teeth,
you just kind of filled with toxins
and you may be overwhelmed in your liver.
But you will spill a lot of tumor markers
that that cancer is displaying.
So, your tumor markers can go up.
This is one of the reasons that I've said this a hundred times.
One of the reasons why a lot of oncologists
don't run tumor markers.
A lot of people will say,
I asked my oncologist about running tumor markers.
He said he doesn't do that.
Why would he not run tumor markers?
Because the oncologist is expecting
that you are going to do what they say to do.
They're expecting you to do chemo and radiation
or whatever they're recommending.
And if you're gonna do tumor markers
and then you're gonna want to get tumor markers done again
while you're doing chemotherapy, they go up
and then you're gonna freak out and go,
oh my gosh, my tumor marker there,
oh my gosh, stop this, it's making me worse
and he's gonna talk you off the ledge.
So, it's better just not to do a little.
That's their mindset.
So, yes, when you kill cancer quickly,
your tumor markers can go up.
Well, yes, it's a simple answer, yes.
Next question.
We have one air purifier that I placed in the bedroom.
Is it important for me to run that 24-7?
Or only really overnight?
Or when I'm otherwise in the bedroom for a good stretch?
Well, remember, an air purifier,
it puts an air purifier that is drying air in,
going through a filter and then throwing air back out.
Number one, you gotta make sure you change the filter
probably twice as often as they recommend.
But number two, you're required air circulation.
And so, the more air that you can bring through
that filtration system and spew out the cleaner it's gonna be.
So, if you have an air purifier like that,
that is filtering the air.
I would run it, I'd run it 24-7.
Next question, I noticed one of those little filter things
came off of some wire on my rife setup.
So, I saw this question.
So, I pulled out this picture.
Are you talking about this thing, this electronic filter thing?
So, these quarter filter things, remember,
those are called ferrite beads or ferrite pores
or ferrite chokes, lots of things to it.
They're made of ferrite.
And they help with electrical conduction
through a wire system so that there's not spikes
in electrical conduction and there's not impedence
through that wire.
You can have loss of frequencies through a wire.
So, we started putting these and some people
that have been with me a long time
because had their rife ball, they have a true rife ball
but they've had it for years and they're like,
what, I've never seen one of those things.
We just started doing this in urethal.
Putting these ferrite cores on the bulb wires.
The bulb wires right when you plug them into the rife
and the bulb wires up at where they go into the bulb itself.
So, there's four of these then on each bulb.
There's two on each wire.
There's also a smaller one on the USB,
actually two of them.
One on where the USB connects to the rife machine itself
and one on where the USB connects to the computer.
It just helps give a nicer electrical frequency.
So, you can test a rife machine by using a cell,
using what's a machine called a oscilloscope.
So, we actually tested the rife bulb.
I didn't, but a friend of mine did with an oscilloscope
and filed that with the ferrite beams.
It was much smoother and stayed at the frequency
that you're trying to run better.
So, you should have four of these,
and they just snap on again.
And you should have four of these on the bulb
and you should have two of them on the USB cord.
So, if you, I have four on the bulb,
but I have two on the USB cord,
I'm going to bet it fell it off some other thing.
A lot of electrical equipment happens, you know.
So, you can buy them on Amazon.
Now, there's different sizes for different cords.
So, they're real inexpensive.
It's a simple, easy thing to add to your sheet
and add to your cord.
We've talked about this before.
I've created a video about this.
The video is on the frequency course.
And so, you can look more there.
Should one have a massage therapy
when you had or have cancer?
Is it bad to do massage when you have cancer?
No, I wouldn't say so.
The only caveat to that would be,
I used to have a massage therapist
that worked for the years ago
and she went and got a separate certification
to do cancer massages.
So, there is some separate training to do cancer massages.
There are certainly things that you wouldn't want
to do, you don't want to.
Okay, if you've never had a massage before,
any good massage therapist would say,
we need to go real shallow, maybe even do just a half hour
of massage to begin with.
You will move a lot of toxins
when you start ripping into the muscles
and digging into the muscles.
Remember, your waist tissue waist
is between the cells in the extracellular spaces
and it can sit there and it's supposed to sit there
until your lip system carries away.
But you could have a lot of waist, a lot of swelling.
And then when you're going to push it around
and push it in, it move it into lip tissue
and have it carried into the liver,
you can make yourself really sick to do it in the massage.
So, I would say go very, very slow
and find somebody who is certified in cancer.
Okay, next question.
I had been, or something else by insurance covered,
this is a cumulative therapy drug.
I've read that it can encourage stem cell growth
and aggressiveness.
Can you explain the difference between cancer cells
and cancer stem cells and how to battle each?
So, cancer is a cell starts with one cell
that then can be damaged and could be a toxin,
could be a pathogen, could be really toxin in cancer.
That can damage the nucleus of the cell
and the cell replicates a damaged cell
and goes into a more rapid rate of replication,
replicating cells that are in a rapid rate of replication.
That's what cancer is.
But as cancer starts to grow, it gives off other cells.
It breaks, some cells break off of that.
And those are called cancer stem cells
or circulating tumor cells.
And I like circulating tumor cells
as far as that term goes because that's what they're doing.
They're circulating around looking for a place
to basically be fueled and to start replicating.
That's what metastasis is.
So, when you have cancer before you're even diagnosed
with cancer, that cancer has already given off
thousands and thousands of circulating tumor cells.
Remember, cancer has to be three million cells large
for it to even be picked up on a CT scanner or a PET scan.
So, it has to be fairly large.
And by the time it's maybe a thousand cells large,
it's starting to give off circulating tumor cells.
So, by the time it's large enough to be,
oh my gosh, I have this mass in my breast.
It has millions and millions and millions of cells large.
But still not millions enough to equate to how much
the pharmaceutical companies are paid just solely
for influencing our congressman, but that's another story.
So, all these cells are breaking off the original cancer
and they're circulating around your body
and they're looking for a place to set up home
and raise a family.
I came up with that terminology years ago,
in my first book, I stuck with it
because that's really what it's doing
if you want to think about it that way.
Those are circulating tumor cells.
Those are cancer stem cells.
So, how do you kill those?
Well, you are doing everything.
You're doing to stimulate your immune system,
you're helping kill cancer cells.
The problem is chemotherapy doesn't kill cancer cells
typically because, well, if chemotherapy is uptaken
by a cancer stem cell, it's going to kill it.
But chemotherapy is going to be more attracted
to cells that are more rapidly replicating,
which cancer stem cells slash circulating tumor cells
are not yet rapidly replicating.
Therefore, the chemotherapy is going to be more attracted
to the cancer that's growing.
So, it could kill the cancer that's growing
and then not kill the circulated tumor cells.
But one of the edge 22s about doing chemotherapy
is it's going to kill cell lines that are rapidly replicating.
That's why it does kill cancer.
But that's why it does doc pure immune system down
because your immune system is a cell line
that is rapidly replicating.
And that's why it can kill hair follicles cells
because hair follicle cells are rapidly replicating.
That's why people doing chemotherapy often lose their hair.
So, it's because chemotherapy is attracted
to cell lines that are rapidly replicating.
That's the positive and the negative of chemotherapy.
Well, then it allows cancer stem cells
to then maybe start growing
because if you're not doing any nutritional things,
if you're not doing the right,
if you're not doing alternative things
along with your chemotherapy,
you're going to have a greater chance
of your those circulating tumor cells
of just taking off because what's been keeping them at bay
is your immune system.
I write a lot about this in my book,
but I'd highly recommend if you haven't read my book,
Stop by the Cancer and Start killing the cause
to read that that will help you understand some of this stuff.
Because if you're only getting your stuff
off of Instagram and Facebook and stuff,
you're only getting part of the story.
Even though this piece was right,
if you read it that says doing chemotherapy
could encourage stem cell growth and the cancer
and their aggressiveness and metastasis,
it is true.
But the rest of the story is that
that's why you're doing things
other than just standards of care.
So, I've heard people say,
when I talk to them on a case review, they'll say,
I'm trying to decide between doing alternative care
and doing what my ecologist recommends.
You're missing the point.
So the point isn't whether I'm going to do alternative care
or standard conventional care.
The point is you have to do alternative care
and you even have to do it even more so
if you're going to do standards of care.
It's not really an option
that you're not going to do alternative care
and people that don't do alternative things
are going to have a poorer outcome for reasons just like this.
So if you don't do other things
to build up your immune system
and to help you kill cancer stem cells,
slash circulated tumor cells,
and you only do chemotherapy,
you're not going to have a good outcome.
So I do explain it in more depth in my book too.
So not to say that you want to read a 600-page book
just did, you know, we're going to begin,
but it can be helpful to kind of start clowing through them.
Next question, I read that iodide deficiency
can increase the incidence of ovarian cancer.
Would it be wise to add that to my protocol?
I don't think so.
So I test everybody for iodide
and I am, you know, there's,
there was some alternative therapy information out there,
especially back in the 70s and 80s.
And there's a practitioner,
I think he might even still be a practice thing,
he's older than me,
but he wrote a book about iodide in breast cancer.
And the data is, it was just,
I don't know that it was really all true.
So I'm using iodide
and topically on breast tumors,
I think it's a wise thing to do
with breast tumors, especially as I hope it does.
But I don't know that taking iodide
orally is a wise thing to do.
For multiple reasons,
I do speak more about iodide
and how it affects the thyroid
in the chronic disease
in autoimmune course in the last section of the thyroid.
So I'm very against using iodide
as a nutritional supplement
because of the fact that it's going to produce ashymodos,
which is an autoimmune disease in the thyroid
and just about everybody that does that.
So you have to be careful with iodide.
So of course, I test with the cheek swab
that's a purpose of the cheek swab I have.
So somebody listed it so it's like,
you told me to take iodide,
well, it's because it tested for you.
So, but it's not very common.
Next question, do you recommend castor oil packs
for cancer patients?
Yes, so there's information in your binder
about castor oil packs.
There's a bunch of information on our website
on castor oil packs
with instructions
but where you place the castor oil pack is very important.
So I don't recommend doing castor oil packs
over the cancer.
So we have had numerous people that, sorry,
but watched an Instagram video
and they were told, if you have breast cancer,
you should put a castor oil pack over that spot.
No, it'll cure your breast cancer
and they were made worse because of that.
Multiple women, I've talked to, that has happened to,
not just one or two.
I'm not a fan of using castor oil packs
right over the cancer.
Where I'm a fan of is using castor oil packs over the liver.
So you could use castor oil packs over the liver
as a way to help with detoxification as a way
and you put heat over that so it was a way
to help decrease the viscosity of the bile,
help with gallbladder flow, bile flow,
it helps with phase four of the detoxification process.
Next question.
I'd like to purchase a glucometer.
Is there anyone of the many out there
that are okay or are there other factors
that make one better than another?
No, I just would go to Target or Walgreens
or Wal-Mart or something and get a glucometer.
It's not like you're going to be picking your figure every day.
I don't suggest that.
People that have diabetes that have to check their blood
sugar on a daily basis, it's much better to get those units
that attach to your skin and you read them
if you're cold and stuff that's much easier
than picking your figure every day
and you're going to get calluses on your figures.
But you're only going to do it maybe a couple of times
a week to begin with than maybe once a week or so.
So yeah, you could get any problems.
The latest offerings on social media,
oh, there's social media.
There's a Vegas Derb stimulator.
It's a portable PDF device that you wear like a necklace.
What are your thoughts about that?
This person did give me a list of information on it.
I am not a fan of those things.
You have to be very, very careful
because people like me, I started talking
about autonomic nervous system balance
when I first started dealing with people with cancer.
I used to talk about it before that back in the 80s
but especially when you're dealing with cancer.
It's very big on Gonzalez's framework of dealing
with cancer, trying to get people more
into a parasympathetic tone, a sympathetic overdrive.
It's not good for anybody.
If this is all new terminology to you,
go to our website or go to the member site.
Either one, look up, sympathetic, parasympathetic.
You start typing that in.
Remember, on our website,
there is a little magnifying glass thing
that you can click on and you can search.
Remember, we have over 2,000 blogs
probably on our website.
Most of them have videos on it.
Also, you can go to our video site.
So you go to videos.com or it's clinic.com.
We have over 3,000 videos on all sorts of different things.
How I don't have one on this,
this is really good question.
So I'm not saying anything bad about the question
but what I do want you to watch
is the video that I created
to help you understand the difference
between sympathetic and parasympathetic tone.
And also on that blog post
on where that video is contained on our website
also has a PDF download for vagal stimulation,
neurological vagal stimulation exercises,
and sympathetic or part of the brain
that houses the sympathetic is called the mesencephalium.
So it's mesencephalic call-meat exercises.
So if you download those two,
those are going to be your best bet on how to help balance that.
Your parasympathetic nervous system
is what calms you, decreases heart rate
and slows your tone.
It opens up your vessels, it relaxes you
and stimulates your nervous system
and stimulates detoxification.
Your sympathetic nervous system is the opposite of that.
It's your fight or flight mechanisms.
It's when you're in business constant anxiety state.
It's when you're nervous, it's when you're stressed.
Your sympathetic nervous system has a purpose.
It's not bad.
You have to have a good sympathetic tone
but it has to be in balance with the parasympathetics.
If you're just overly parasympathetic
you're not going to get off the couch to do anything today.
But if you're overly sympathetic
you're going to be full of inner anxiety.
Even if you don't see it on the outside
and your immune system is going to be suppressed,
your detoxification is going to be suppressed.
Your heart rate is going to be higher.
Your blood pressure is going to be higher
because it increases your, it decreases the tone
of your anodilial musculature.
And that's not a good state to stay in.
But we need to have that state.
We need to have a healthy sympathetic nervous system.
But bear jumps out in front of you.
You need to be able to react to that situation,
that deadly situation.
But your sympathetic should kick in
and your adrenals kick in
and you were able to run away from that bear
because your blood pressure goes up.
But in doing so you escape from that danger
but you also are not worried about sexual function
at that time.
You're not worried about detoxification.
You're not worried about fighting a virus.
This bear is going to eat you.
So you have most people when they hear that they have cancer
are in a sympathetic overdrive.
A lot of people are in a sympathetic overdrive
even if they don't have cancer.
So stimulating your parasympathetics is very valuable.
Well, that has also pushed a lot of influencers
to push products that are just much focused products.
So you have to be careful about social media again.
So do ask these questions on the Zoom
so we clarify some of this stuff.
There really isn't any tools out there.
That's the really reason why you're doing coffee enemas
is to help stimulate your parasympathetics.
That's why you should download those PDFs
and do some of those other exercises
they've been shown through peer-reviewed studies
to stimulate your parasympathetics
and to calm your sympathetic.
So don't underestimate those things.
Use those things.
Those are at your disposal.
Those are on the member side.
They're on our website.
Next question.
We received the Rupa blood kit and it said
I don't have to fast for the tests.
Okay, the only test really that you have to fast for
if you want a real accurate number is the glucose.
So I don't, sometimes I don't check that box
because that's not what we're looking for.
If we were testing somebody that has diabetes
and we're doing another check on them,
I would check that box that they inform you
that I'm requiring you to fast.
That's all it is.
So really it's the only thing that if you go,
if you get breakfast and you go to your Rupa blood test,
the only thing that's going to be thrown on is the glucose.
So we're not really looking at the glucose.
At this point, the person who asked this question,
this is a subsequent test.
So we already know he doesn't have diabetes.
So that's why I haven't emptied out the capsules
for a week to see if I'm allergic to the coating
to see if this was causing my post nasal drip.
I spoke to this person about this.
They had a question I think last week or the week before.
It seems to have helped.
It's wondering if some of those supplements come in a form
rather than a capsule.
I can check.
I'll check.
If you can send me an email to rely me,
that would be great too.
But I'll check and see if we can,
I'll have to get a cheek swab for me in a test.
But I can check and see if there's some
or general that I could swamp on.
So this person is having post nasal drip and I said,
it could be, you're taking a lot of capsules,
it could be the capsule that you could be
developing a sensitivity to.
That is a possibility.
We've talked about this on the Zoom call before
with other people.
And I've had people do this and they emptied out the capsule
into their smoothie and their symptom
and it was a post nasal drip and something else.
Like usually it's like got stomachache or something.
So that's good.
I mean, that's, you know, anything's possible.
You can develop a sensitivity to anything.
So, most of my life I have had dry skin on my hands.
If I didn't use lotion enough, often enough,
I would have stabbing pain in addition to the dryness.
Now I have itchy dry skin with stabbing pain
all over my body that has been torturing me for three months.
The telephone conversation about a month ago,
I think you mentioned that itchy
was common with Hodgkin's lymphoma.
I don't like to take pharmaceutical medicines to treat it.
I tried multiple lotions with natural remedies.
100% organic coconut oil is the only thing
that brings some relief when applied,
but it doesn't do enough.
I pain and discomfort is constant at a six out of 10
that sometimes goes to a nine out of 10
at the worst moments when my body temperature changes.
You know, if anything safe for my body
could help with this pain.
Also, the flavor of food is not the same as the aroma
I'm spelling.
This seems strange to me.
I'm taking at least 50 micrograms of sick daily
for weeks without noticing any improvement.
Any thoughts on how to remedy this?
So this person has Hodgkin's lymphoma
and I told him when he spoke to him a while back
that he was complaining about itchy.
So that's actually how he found out he had Hodgkin's lymphoma.
So anyhow, how can you deal with this?
Is it topical?
Well, do we topical things be help?
But as this person's experiencing,
it's not helping that much.
Problem is is what's happening with the white blood cells
internal.
So if you don't work at killing the cancer
and docky those cells down, it's an internal thing.
It's much like if I have a histamine reaction
and so I break out on my skin and I get to put
something topically on my skin.
Well, that might give you some relief
but the problem really is the histamine reaction internal.
So one of the things I do recommend
with lymphoma because there is little known
about why a person has this symptom
because not everybody with lymphoma has this symptom
is that possibility of defects in histamine genes
so they just don't get rid of the histamine
that's caused from the white blood cell reaction.
So there is a histamine gene called the HNMT gene
which gets rid of histamine in the tissue.
So normally histamine will give histamine a bad name
that if you remember everything isn't all bad or all good
but too much of anything can be a bad thing.
So too much histamine can cause all sorts of problems
and this is one of them.
So using product like their histamine scavenger
would be the first thing I would go to.
I would try that to decrease the histamine.
That's what I would do.
So I would treat it still from an external perspective
to help with immediate symptoms
but trying to decrease inflammatory cytokines,
not just histamine.
So histamine is an inflammatory cytokine
that is a signaling chemical that signals
our immune system to attack an enemy.
So but there's other inflammatory cytokines
that are doing the same thing.
So the product, the clear histamine scavenger
is a broad spectrum product to help get rid of those.
So that's what I would start with.
I was recently diagnosed with a mild urinary tract infection.
The driving bacteria was ephysylysis.
I found this interesting because I have been
having an unexplatable two sensitivity
on my right side of my mouth, upper and lower
which is where I had a root canal
that had failed once after eight years redone
and then finally removed the tubes four years ago.
But I researched this bacteria that said
that it is a bacteria that's often found in root canal teeth.
Interesting, that's why root,
one of the other reason my root canals are good for us.
The doctor prescribed nitroferistone 100 milligrams
to treat the UTI.
And now the sensitivity my teeth is getting better.
Is there a right program that kills this bacteria?
Possibly the root canal dental foci program.
I understand this is very resistant.
Okay, so a couple of things we learned for this question.
There were one we learned that I'm not very good at reading
names of drugs.
Number two, we learned that root canals can be bad
because they can harbor bacteria.
So your teeth, we think are just like non-living bone
but your teeth have a blood supply and a nerve supply.
And that's what's destroyed in a root canal.
So a root canal is going down to the root
and you're destroying the nerve
and you're destroying the blood supply.
So now the two just becomes a hotel for bacteria
that you're even if you take a whole bunch of immune nutrition
and you have the best immune system on the planet,
it can't kill that bacteria
because there's no blood supply to that area.
So your immune system, your white blood cells are getting there.
So their life living there and just waiting for opportunities
to go out and attack your body.
We see thermograms of people with breast cancer,
let's say they have breast cancer and they're left breast
and they have a red hot white spot on their lower jaw
on the left and there's a line running right down to the breast.
Giving credence to the fact that some breast cancers
are actually run pathogens that originated
from an involved infection that was never diagnosed.
So I'm not a fan of root canals if we can help them.
I'm a fan of getting rid of root canal teeth
if we're able to do that
because they can harbor bacteria that could make us sick
for a long period of time.
And this person's talking about not breast issues
but UTI issues.
And this person is talking about
it must have actually had a swab and had the bacteria tested.
Now, interesting about there's a lot of different bacteria,
a lot of different aimed viruses as well.
Now, I don't know this person that's asking this question
has a true right?
So I don't know, I have to look at new true right?
I'll see if there's a frequency for that.
I highly doubt it.
But I will tell you this and I wasn't gonna announce this yet.
But I have given a few people a program.
So I might as well announce it.
I said a while ago, I did announce this several months ago
that we are getting a computer program
that we're able to get the exact frequencies
from the National Institute of Health website
of every pathogen that exists.
Now, there are pathogens that are known
to be contributors to a lot of different cancers.
Only the only frequencies that I have so far
for prostate cancer and their higher frequencies
so they don't work on the true right yet.
So they only work on the Tilly Arab and some two people
that have prostate cancer and have a Tilly Arab
and I sent out a prostate pathogen program.
So eventually, over the next three months,
I'm gonna be developing an entire different program.
So understand, all the programs on the Tilly Arab,
if you haven't a Tilly Arab,
I have either written completely
or I have adjusted and put into the 11th harmonic.
So I have had my hands on every single one of the programs
in the Tilly Arab, if you haven't a Tilly Arab.
If you have a true right,
I did not write all those programs.
So those who are written, you know,
will buy a lot of different practitioners
over a lot of different years.
And there really is not anybody writing any more
true right programs.
That's why we're telling you not to update your true right programs
like we used to tell people,
update your programs every three to six months or every year.
Do not do that anymore.
If you haven't heard that,
this is the first time you're hearing this.
I have it all over the frequency healing course.
I have it on the member site,
dot to update your true right programs
because they're not doing that anymore.
Nobody's writing new ones.
However, when I get this program
ready from National Institutes of Health,
I am going to write new pathogen programs for the true right.
And I got to update all my pathogen programs
for the Tilly Arab.
So regardless of whether you have a true right
for a Tilly Arab and you're going to be getting a flash drive
with a whole mess of pathogen programs
and you'll be getting a flash drive
and probably put on the same flash drive.
A program for your specific cancer based upon the pathogens.
Now, the reason why they have to be totally different programs
is because the way you write programs for true right
for completely different than the way you write programs
for the Tilly Arab.
It's way harder to write it on the true right
because true right board is not stable enough
so you have to do all these different duty cycles
and some total pain and the rear end takes away long your time
but I'm still going to do it.
So and the true right doesn't let you go beyond 10,000 hurts
where a lot of these frequencies for the pathogens
are, you know, in the 20,000 hurt range.
The Tilly Arab and let's you go up to 30,000 hurts.
So that's a big reason why we switched
because I knew this program was coming out.
Now, it's no one else is doing it.
So you guys are going to have these programs.
So at this time right now, I don't know
that there is a program for this bacteria.
There's going to be, so it's not going to help you right now
but it's going to help you in the future.
So that's what's coming down the pike.
Oh yes, Kelly, you do have the Tilly Arab in too.
So you'll be one of the first to get there.
Okay, next question is it okay for me to be on the greens
first capsules.
To remember, I've announced that the greens first
has changed their formula that they added,
their new formula they added methyl groups.
And I had a discussion with the owner of greens first
and said, well, you know, unless I have a cancer patient
that's stable, I don't want them on excess methyl groups.
But their cancer is growing.
We don't want them on excess methyl groups.
So he's actually going to reformulate it for me
and he's going to, he's supposed to be getting back to me.
This was three weeks ago, I had this meeting with him.
So he's supposed to be getting back to me with what he has to,
I think he said he has to wait until he's ready to second batch
because they run these giant batches
and they have to sell out the first batch
before he could run another batch.
He's taking on the methyl groups.
So if can a person that has cancer be taking methyl groups?
There's methyl groups in the greens.
Yes, they can, but we don't want excess methyl groups.
So anywhere we could prevent excess methyl groups.
So clearly at all my new patients,
I'm not putting them on greens first,
we're using the designs for health essential greens.
So the only thing I don't like about that product
is it's a little more expensive, but it doesn't have any methyl groups.
So we're getting that corrected.
So hopefully that would be corrected very soon.
Okay, we have some questions coming in on the chat.
Did I just hear you say to use my diet
topically on an open breast wound?
I believe I just opened it up.
I have a small scab over the tumor
that I put a healing natural salve on every day.
It doesn't seem to be getting worse,
but what would applied iodide do for me?
How do I do it?
Topically, I have some 2% new gall solution at home already.
Yeah, you could do that.
It's iodide topically can kill bacteria.
It's not from a topical standpoint.
So that's just another thing.
So if a person has an open wounded cancer,
I always suggest hydrogen peroxide over there.
There's all sorts of other different salves
and stuff that can be helpful.
B-17 creed to a whole bunch of different salves
that can be helpful.
Even essential oils if you use a carrier oil with it.
But iodide can be another option.
And you can rotate those things
and see which one seems to be healing better.
Everybody's a little bit different,
so test them out, try them.
Next question.
I was reading about the importance of garlic,
ginger, turmeric, cayenne pepper to fight cancer.
One of my supplements is the turmeric ginger combination.
Would you recommend adding more and adding the cayenne pepper?
The recommendation was fresh garlic in your meal regularly
and a pinch of cayenne pepper a couple times a week
or whatever you could tolerate.
Do you have any thoughts on this?
Well, I'm a huge fan of cayenne pepper.
Cayenne pepper is so good for your heart as well.
So in aerovac medicine, cayenne pepper
is considered a hot spice.
I think garlic and ginger are also
and they don't recommend it for cancer,
except that's not what the literature shows at all.
All of those can be extremely beneficial for cancer.
So remember, too much of a good thing can be a bad thing,
but these are just herbs that you really can't
open for those on them.
The only thing that I would say about it
is you have to be careful with the ginger,
or excuse me, with the garlic,
is that garlic is your strongest blood
that are from a natural perspective that exists.
So again, I'm a huge fan of garlic.
I think it could kill bacteria,
kill viruses, kill pathogens, kill parasites.
It's in the paraclear.
Garlic is a good thing,
except garlic is a blood that are,
so if you are out of blood that are medication,
you have to be careful with garlic.
Or if you're bruised easy,
So you have to keep an eye on that.
If you have any vascular fragility,
you need that you're bruised easy.
Oh my gosh, I don't get that big giant bruise on the hand.
Oh my gosh, look at this bruise, I got a bad leg.
I didn't see this.
If you're bruised easy, be careful with taking too much garlic.
If you have a wound that's trying to heal,
let's say you're just in surgery,
maybe you don't want to do garlic.
So if you are bleeding,
if you have an open wound and you're bleeding too much garlic,
it's gonna be a blood thinner.
You're not gonna be clotting as fast.
You could bleed more.
So just be careful with garlic.
Next question.
I have a very runny nose since my chemo.
I believe that overnight,
I end up swallowing mucus regularly.
I have nausea every morning that dissipates by afternoon.
Could this be a cause of my runny nose?
I work with a homeopath who recommended I take
estimate hydrochloricone that is a homeopath for histamine.
To try to stop the runny nose is this safe to add?
It's pretty much safe to add any homeopath.
So yes, you could add that.
So yeah, taking even over the counter
and histamine can like you try that
because yeah, that could be a problem.
And the runny nose is probably basically an immune reaction,
basically an allergic type reaction to the chemo
because it's a chemical that's nasty.
So you can't really prevent that.
But you could do endohistamines can be good for cancer.
So you can take it over the counter
and a histamine if you wanted to as well.
Next question.
If I have a container and a half of new greens powder
should I be taking it?
Should I be taking it in my smoothie?
You mean you have a container a half of the greens first powder?
Yes, you could.
So we want to.
So you.
I can't right now.
So should you be taking that with your spoon?
So I'm not totally understanding that question.
So you can you can.
I'm going to get on that.
Let me know.
You choose to just one second shoot.
I'm taking metal groups for my high homelessness.
Yes.
So that is the caveat that so if you have high
homelessness, you really have to.
So that's okay.
By the way, just other supplements I've been taking
I just got a can of greens first.
So you if the person if a person has high homelessness,
you have to take metal groups for a period of time.
Once you get that down to an acceptable level,
then you can go off or go down.
So that is just an issue that you have.
So was this.
You stay see saying yes, that's the greens first that you have.
Yeah, I would go ahead and use that up.
Where you're at with your cancer.
I think you're fine to use it up with the switch to the
essential greens.
I ordered my greens first from full scripts.
So maybe it's an old version.
Yeah, you should just look and see if there's metal,
metal, tender, hydrofolate, you're not.
They should have the new stuff on the full script too.
So I have been having rib pain, especially under my armpit.
Hurts especially with deep breaths.
I suspect I have to rate damage to my boss up.
Player is it okay to put a castor oil wrap on this overnight?
Yeah, I'd say so.
You can do other tissue to help your help,
but right and things like that.
I would just stay away from the cancer itself
with the castor of that.
Any other questions?
Okay, really good questions today.
Thanks everybody for the great questions.
It's always hard when we don't get any questions.
So I really do appreciate all of you.
And we'll see you guys next week.
All right.
Bye.